Ah, t'es déjà là ok, bah je viens t'ouvrir. Bouge pas.
Oh ! P**e !
Je déteste quand je regarde un film
ou une série dans les transports
et que mon voisin peut la suivre
avec les sous-titres.
C'est ma série, OK ? Tu ne la regarde pas.
C'est mon abonnement.
Je déteste quand les gens font des story,
y'a des moments cool
mais je suis le seul à pas avoir remarqué.
Il m'a tagué en plus.
Oh le bâtard.
Je déteste marcher à 3 sur
un trottoir trop petit
du coup, tu marches comme
un con, derrière
Alors moi je propose une petite invention
ROTATION !
Tous les 50 mètres, toutes les 2 minutes,
une petite rotation
Tout le monde est content.
Je déteste les gens qui, au lieu de
t'envoyer un grand message
Ils t'en envoient pleins,
pleins de petits
On envoit un grand message
avec toutes les infos, simple, carré
une seule notif, tout le monde
est content, OK ?
Je déteste quand on dit quelque chose
que je ne comprends pas
- De quoi ?
- Et on me dit...
Non rien.
Non, tu allais dire un truc là...
Non, non, t'inquiètes.
J'ai besoin de savoir à ce moment là !
Écoute, tu vas me répéter ce que tu as dit
parce que je mérite de savoir, OK ?
J'ai dit, si t'avais vu Koh-Lanta hier
mais je me suis souvenu que tu regardais pas.
Non, je regarde pas Koh-Lanta, non.
Et en attendant
(inaudible)
T'as dit quoi?
Non, rien.
Oh le bâtard.
Je déteste les gens qui envoient
des vocaux interminables
pour dire un tout petit truc.
Yo, mec j'espère que ça va,
moi ça va écoute...
Du coup je rêve d'une fonctionnalité
"Ignorer l'inutile"
Pardon c'est pas ça dont
je voulais te parler
Attends, j'ai un autre truc que
je voulais te dire
Je suis chez moi en ce moment, ouais.
Ça me ferait gagner tellement de temps.
Ça va ?
Faut trop qu'on se fasse une bouffe.
Il faut qu'on prenne un verre.
Ouais carrément, on fait comme ça.
À bientôt, salut !
Je déteste quand je dis "au revoir"
à quelqu'un
Et en fait, on part dans la même
direction longtemps
Tu sais quoi ? Je vais faire semblant
de faire mes lacets
comme ça tu prends de l'avance.
Ouais on fait ça,
c'est mieux, merci.
Je déteste quand j'ai l'impression que
le son de mon téléphone est cassé
Pourquoi j'entends rien ?
Alors qu'en fait il était juste connecté
à l'enceinte Bluetooth du salon
Attends, je suis à fond là ?
Bon, je déteste les gens qui utilisent
30 messageries différentes.
Je te l'ai envoyé par SMS
ou en Snap.
En DM insta je crois.
Mais tu veux pas utiliser
une seule messagerie?
Franchement c'est l'enfer avec toi.
- WhatsApp ?
- Ouais, WhatsApp.
Après si tu fais une Story sur Insta
- je peux réagir avec un emoji flamme
- Insta OK
Quand on Game ?
Discord
- Pour les contenus trash...
- Snapchat.
Oh ! D'ailleurs, tu connais Telegram ?
Non, c'est quoi ?
On peut pas se mettre d'accord
sur une seule ?
Celle que vous voulez, je m'en branle
mais une seule
Je déteste les gens qui prennent l'escalier
quand moi je prends l'escalator
Ils le font exprès. Déjà d'aller plus vite
et de me faire culpabiliser de pas
faire d'activités sportives.
Je vous montre ma prochaine vidéo,
OK ? C'est une exclu.
Je déteste quand je prête mon téléphone
et que j'entends que j'ai des notifications.
À ce moment-là, j'ai toujours
l'impression que c'est
les pires notifs qui apparaissent.
Mais lisez pas le...
Faut pas lire... les trucs...
Putain, fais chier, ok, voilà
Non mais je vous l'enverrai plus tard
quand ça sortira.
Je déteste les gens qui ont des prénoms
on ne peut plus classique
mais avec une écriture un peu différente.
Girard point Christelle...
Non, Christelle avec un K
Christelle avec un K ?
K
Y. T'as mis un "i".
Un seul L
et y'a pas de E.
- D'accord.
- Voilà.
@gmail.com
Alors non, jaimail, comme j'ai un mail
donc J A I M A I L
"jaimail", ok.
Je déteste les mots de passe WIFI
Est ce que c'est un "i" majuscule ?
Est ce que c'est un "L" ?
Est-ce qu'il faut mettre les tirets ?
C'est juste pour séparer ou il faut
vraiment taper les tirets ?
On sait pas, c'est chiant.
Ça marche ! C'est bon.
Les tirets c'est des vrais tirets,
c'est pas des faux tirets.
De toute façon, y'a un QR code.
Et je déteste quand quelqu'un
m'apprend quelque chose
que j'aurais dû savoir depuis longtemps.
Ouais mais moi je préfère les taper.
Je trouve ça... c'est mieux.
Ouais, c'est plus chiant.
Je déteste les pandémies mondiales
ça c'est pas trop ma tasse de thé.
Je déteste quand je me matte une série
ou un film, calmement.
L'interface de lecture veut pas s'en aller.
J'attends un peu, j'attends encore.
Là ça devient chiant.
Au bout d'un moment je me dis OK,
il faut que je bouge la souris alors
et bien sûr l'interface s'en va
quand je bouge la souris.
Je déteste les gens qui me
corrigent tout le temps.
D'ailleurs, j'ai vu ta dernière vidéo.
Tu dis "pandémie mondiale"
mais c'est pas français.
C'est un pléonasme parce que
"Pan" dans "pandémie" ça veut dire "tout"
- Et sinon ça t'a plu la vidéo ?
- J'ai laissé un commentaire
Merci beaucoup.
Je déteste tous les groupes
de discussion.
J'ai le droit ou pas ?
Moi ça me saoule.
Déjà, les noms c'est n'importe quoi,
parfois c'est un emoji
tu sais plus qui est dedans.
Alors là y a que les cousins mais
du côté de la mère. Chiant.
Je déteste ce moment
où j'ai fais tomber mon téléphone portable
et je dois le retourner pour voir si
l'écran est pété ou non.
C'est les secondes plus longues de ma vie
Je déteste quand quelqu'un me montre
un meme en anglais que je comprends pas.
Tu me l'envoies ?
Tu me l'envoies aussi ?
Snap ? Insta... Telegram !
Je déteste
quand le livreur me dit "bon appétit"
et que je réponds "vous aussi"
Quand je marche dans de l'eau
avec mes chaussettes
Je déteste les gens qui disent :
Attends mais t'as pas vu ce film ?
Les décharges électriques.
Je déteste aussi les gens qui disent :
Tiret du 8...
Quand il se passe ça.
Ou ça.
Je déteste les gens qui font
pas attention dans la rue.
Pardon ! Merde !
Je suis désolée.
Ça va?
Il a rien ?
Ton portable, il n'a rien ?
Non, il est bien...
- Ça va ?
- Ça va ouais.
OK, j'ai eu peur parce que là c'est...
Non mais c'est moi aussi
j'ai pas regardé...
Mais t'inquiètes c'est nous
enfin on s'est... je suis désolée.
Pas de souci.
- Bonne bonne journée.
- Bonne journée !
- Au revoir.
- Salut au revoir.
Toi aussi tu vas...
Ouais, j'ai mon métro là.
Ah oui.
D'ailleurs ton lacet est défait.
Ah ouais, non mais c'est pas grave
C'est pas grave.
Et donc c'est pour ça que moi
je suis dans le quartier...
Mais ton téléphone il est vraiment
éclaté, quand même.
Non, franchement, ça va.
Mais je suis vraiment désolée,
je regardais pas devant moi
parce que j'étais sur mon téléphone
parce qu'on m'a envoyé un meme
et il m'a fait trop rire.
Regarde.
Ah ouais !
Je le connais celui-là. Des barres.
Je suis prof d'anglais, je donne
des cours d'anglais
Si tu veux.
Ah non mais j'ai compris !
- Ah oui ?
- Ah oui je t'assure, j'ai compris.
D'accord, ok.
Et tu fais quoi toi dans la vie ?
Alors, au jour d'aujourd'hui moi je suis...
Ah ! Pardon mais...
C'est "à ce jour".
"Au jour d'aujourd'hui" ça se dit pas,
c'est un pléonasme
Oui, mais t'inquiètes pas, beaucoup
de gens font l'erreur
Tu fais bien de me le dire parce que
- j'allais encore faire la connerie.
- Non y'a pas de problème.
Donc à ce jour...
Bon, d'accord, j'avoue
je déteste pas mal de choses.
Oui, c'est le métro.
- Bon trajet, bon métro
- Peut-être trop de choses même.
Ouais, ça marche.
Salut.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je fasse?
Je me disais peut être qu'on
peut garder contact ?
Ouais grave !
- Que je change ?
- T'as Insta ?
Ok, Insta, très bien.
Comment tu t'appelles ?
Louane 77.
Louane.
Alors, non, c'est "Lou" comme le loup.
- L'animal.
- D'accord.
Tiret du 8, Anne.
J'ai jamais vu écrit comme ça.
Ouais c'est original.
Ouais c'est joli. Hop, je t'ai ajouté.
Regarde c'est bon, j'ai la notif.
Peut-être à la prochaine, je sais pas.
Je sais ce que vous dites, quelqu'un
qui déteste autant
C'est qu'il lui manque forcément
quelque chose
(inaudible)
- De quoi ?
- Ou quelqu'un.
Non, rien.
Salut.
Quelqu'un qui ferait qu'on apprécie
les choses qu'on détestait.
Alors là, peut être, je pourrais changer.
Elle envoie plein de petits messages...
Ça, c'est vraiment chiant.
Pourquoi les gens font ça?
Franchement, à un moment,
faut connaître ses limites.
Et là, je suis désolé, mais je peux pas.
Voilà j'y peux rien, c'est comme ça.
Et ça me va très bien.